Israel is being accused of staging a
video reportedly showing the surrender
of Hamas soldiers so the footage on
social media shows several dozen men
stripped to their underwear Israeli
media say that these are Hamas Fighters
arrested at the jabalia refugee camp and
one man is seen walking towards a
soldier and handing over a rifle and a
handgun but note here how he's carrying
the rifle in his left hand however Al
jaz's verification unit Sen has
identified a second take of that exact
same video and the Palestinian man is
now holding the rifle in his right hand
like the first video he walks forward to
place the weapons in front of the
Israeli soldiers we're now joined by
mwan bishar he's Al jazer senior
political analyst Marwan not only that
but our reporters in fact say the man is
well known in Gaza to be the owner of an
aluminium work shop and he was kidnapped
apparently in the north of Gaza to what
extent do these videos undermine
Israel's uh public diplomacy strategy
that they're trying to put out I think
it does undermine it but that's not of
course why they do it they do it for the
opposite effect and that's how it is
today with propaganda right propaganda
is an art it's the Art of Lying Israel
used to be great at it Israel used to be
the best spinner there is Netanyahu
himself was a great spinner but with
time Israel has lost its touch now this
Auto propaganda that is meant to
manipulate the friends but not exactly
deceive the enemies is not working very
well in an environment when everyone can
see a video we live in a global
environment when you might want to tell
something to the Israelis but every else
is watching not just the Israelis and
they're doing it badly as well right
once upon a time they used to spin it
brilliantly and what is the spin what is
at the heart of the spin at the heart of
the spin is a schizophrenic Israel it's
both a victim vitim and a victimizer it
has to appear really strong humiliate
the Palestinians do whatever it takes
kill bomb injure and so on so forth
destroy buildings hospitals schools but
at the same time Israel is the victim of
of Hamas terrorism Israel is the victim
of Arab hostility and hatred and it
tries to play and balance always these
two ideas that it's both a victim but
it's also very strong it's the strongest
army in the Middle East right
but when you try to do that in a global
environment when you are trying to show
such poorly done propaganda like we've
seen at the hospitals right you become
the laughing stock of the International
Community of a whole generation that's
quite Savvy looks at those videos and
can tell especially when something like
Al jazer also exposes it for what it is
a Lie the way you have double takes and
we used to have these double takes at
the hospitals remember when they had
this uh grab and go back behind the
X-ray machine it used to had one gun in
the first take and then it had two guns
two machine guns in the second take so
they're actually really becoming quite
terrible so what's going wrong for them
I mean you just said that they used to
be very brilliant at this type of thing
and now they're making very obvious
mistakes when they put out this video
this is a great question but of course
it will take forever to explain what is
happening to Israel Israel is becoming
quite vulgar quite an exhibitionist
State and we've seen that in the
character of nanahu himself when you're
fanatic when you're running a country
that is becoming more fascist or more
fanatic Fanatics are not good at
propaganda it takes liberals to be good
at propaganda that's why is that's why
Israel is looking like Isis today
Israel's those images look like Isis
they look like the the fascists in the
second world war because this these
images are reminders of what happened to
the Jews and to others in Hungary and
Poland and so on so forth how the Nazis
really were so sadistic towards their
victims in Poland and other places and
not just the Jews other so when you
start showing Vic when you start showing
uh uh images like that so sadistic so
humiliating so
dehumanizing maybe you're trying to tell
a certain segment of the Israeli and the
Western public opinion that you are
brilliant but the rest of the
International Community and arguably
even in the west itself they're looking
at this and say wait a minute this
reminds us of images we've seen before
this is horrible what you're doing to
the Palestinians
second Israel keeps saying that we are
not like Hamas we are an Enlighten
democracy we are the only democracy in
the Middle East and then Israel's def
def Defenders supporters say well Hamas
does worse things to our captives than
what Israel does but Israel presumably
is a democracy it's not supposed to be
like Hamas or like Isis it's supposed to
be something presumably different that's
why it's getting these billions of
dollars from the United States that's
why plays basketball in European leagues
not in third world leagues right that's
why it's getting all the preferential
agree uh treatment in the west because
it's supposed to be Western but when it
acts like Isis when it acts like
fascists and it sells us propaganda that
doesn't even work Once Upon a Time the
propaganda used to be we have to kill
the Palestinians we have no choice we
need to kill the Arabs because it's our
existence at stake and hence we used to
call it or they to call it
Yim in Hebrew they're shooting and
crying but when you look at the images
from Gaza today they're all shooting and
laughing we see one video after another
video by Israeli soldiers how they're
destroying toy toy shops right right how
they are bombing a school and the
Israeli soldiers is on the phone with
his daughter saying this bombing is for
you on your birthday you can't be such a
sadist such a dehumanizer such a fascist
and at the same time be good at
propaganda that's why I think this
propaganda is blowing up in their faces
they're becoming bad at it and they're
becoming the laughing stock of the
International Community thank you so
much
bish